I want to take a couple of minutes to
tell you about a project we've been
partnering with called Invictus capital
they worked with us to produce this
video and you can learn more about what
they do by looking at the link right
underneath the video so invictus capital
was founded in 2017 and since day one
their project has been rooted in one
mantra which is that investments should
be democratized transparent accessible
and affordable and what they did was
develop a platform using blockchain
technology that allows investors to
diversify their portfolio through it is
essentially the first-ever
cryptocurrency equivalent to an index
fund which is called crypto 20 and since
then they've already launched a number
of really interesting initiatives
including a VC margin lending crypto
hedging emerging markets and a gold fund
and it's the Invictus Gold Plus fund
that I want to highlight today which
allows you to invest in and earn a yield
on gold it's an open-ended fund that
tracks the underlying gold spot price
through crypto asset gold tokens and the
funds objective is to outperform gold
over the long term the Invictus Gold
Plus fund wants to do this by using
margin lending and arbitrage strategies
to earn a yield over and above the gold
spot price when gold acts as a long-term
inflation hedge and right now you can
invest no fees applied to the first
thousand invested and their new digital
wallet makes the investing process super
simple even with fiat currency the
wallet also gives you access to the
broader invictus blockchain ecosystem so
I've been really intrigued by this this
really it's an investing suite that
Invictus has been developing and
improving over the past few years
they're offering a service that is
definitely different from anything else
we've seen in the crypto investing space
and I would definitely invite any of my
viewers to go and check out their
website learn more about what Invictus
capital is all about if you're someone
who's interested in this type of
investing I'd like to thank
Invictus Capital for partnering with us
to create this video and you can of
course find out more by using the URL
right underneath the video